وننتقل الان الى بيروت والخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي الياس حنا اهلا وسهلا بك عن
دب الياس اذا واضح ان الامور تاخذ منحا
اخر
والتصعيد هو سيد الموقف لان الدبابات
الدبابات من النوع متطور جدا تدخل الان
المعادله كانت تطلب بها تطالب بها
اوكرانيا من فتره والان تحقق لها ما يريد
ولكن لن يتحقق فورا اعمده الياس سيحتاج
الامر الى وقت كيف ستتغير المعادله اذا
على الارض
ليلى همم ليوبار هي جاهزه تقريبا لعده
اسباب اولا يتم التدريب الطواقيم بي
بولندا في بولندا وفي اوروبا تقريبا 2000
دبابه ليوبار 240 منها في بولندا اذا سمح
لها التدريب
اللوجستيه الطريق مفتوح الى همم الى داخل
الاوكراني يبقى التنظيم الاداري كتيبه او
سنيه او ما شابه فاذا نحن امام مرحله
متدرجه من هذا الامر ابعد شيء قد يحصل
قريبا هو دبابات الابرامز ولي اعطائها 31
دبابه ابراج يعني واقع سياسي مختلف تماما
عن اللي يبقى في كيفيه الاستعمال ليله متى
تجهز كيف تدخل ضمن العقيده العسكريه
والاداء على الارض وضد ايه اهداف ليوم همم
اوكرانيا متطلبات الميدانيه والسلاح كبيره
جدا او الاهداف الجيسيه والسياسيه كبيره
جدا مقابل امكانيات محدوده فاذا اين ستكون
المعركه الفاصله باستخدام هذه الدبابات
يعني في انتظار ان تدخل هذه الدبابات
الى الاستعمال همم ربما بعد اشهر كما ذكرت
ويختلف الامر بالنسبه لكل نوع من الدبابات
في هذه الاثناء ما الذي نتوقعه الان همم
كما اوردنا استيقظ سكان كياب على ضربه
جويه كانت الامور قد هدات في كياب الى حد
ما همم وهناك حاله استنفار في اكثر من
منطقه ما الذي يتوقع ان تقوم به همم موسكو
عسكريا في انتظار ان تدخل الدبابات حيز
الاستعمال
ليلى اولا ايه موضوع القصف على المدن هذا
امر مستمر واصبحت سياسه اساسيه اليوم
روسيا ما ينقص روسيه اولا الشروط لا يمكن
للرئيس بوتين ان يخسر مرتين متتاليتين في
اوكرانيا هو يعد العسكر ولكن ايضا لا يمكن
له فتح جبهه تمتد من اكياف وحتى خرسان
تقريبا 1,500 كم هذا الامر جرب في المرحله
الاولى يبقى اليوم عمليه التمواضع
التكتيكي يعني ما يحصل قربه كرمينا
وزلاتوف ما يحصل همم جنوب زباروجا عمليه
تحسين الواقع التكتيكي بانتظار المرحله
الكبرى ويلعب لعبه الوقت على المدى البعيد
بالمعنى هل لدى اوكرانيا العديد الكافي
كلا هل لدى اوكرانيا الدعم الغربي لا
متناهي كلا هو يلعب على هذه الامور لعمليه
استنزاف ان كان الجيش الاوكراني وحتى
الدعم الغربي شكرا جزيلا لك العميد الياس
حنا من بيروت